the Great Atlantic sargassum belt is the
largest seaweed bloom in the world and
it's expanding
visible from space it's a growing
problem for Coastal communities the
beaches genuinely if they aren't
maintained you you just can't go there
you'd be up to your knees in sarcasm but
as a key sequester of carbon this
invasive species also presents an
opportunity we want to gather sargassum
using robotic Vehicles if you sink it
down to those meters our current model
suggest that that particular water body
does not come back in contact with the
atmosphere for at least 100 years
can scientists take a global Challenge
and turn it into an opportunity to buy
time in the race against climate change
[Music]
sargassum has been in the Atlantic since
the time of Christopher Columbus
floating mats of seaweed that gave its
name to the sargasso Sea a nutrient poor
patch of the Atlantic penned in by ocean
currents
you can think of it as a floating
rainforest or an upside down coral reef
because each rafter sargassum is a hot
spot of biological activity
but in the last couple of decades a new
population has emerged further south
near the coast of Brazil and the
Caribbean
new 2011 you know we were all taken back
by this with this new phenomenon where
we saw tons of sargasm being brought and
beached in the region based in Barbados
scientists and entrepreneur Shelly Ann
Cox specializes in fisheries management
she first noticed the impact of
sargassum on the sea urchin divers she
was working with
Fisher Fort have reported you know sorry
guys I'm not as far as their eyes can
see some of them can get to to the boats
or the boats can't get through the sand
dungeon to get out
those near shore the spirit fissures as
well they reported some of their skin
being irritated when they're diving and
the berries that keep the surrogato
floating have gotten into their ears as
well
the impact on tourism the lifeblood of
the Caribbean has been huge this weed is
going right up to the desalination plant
by Barnacle Point people get ready for
this smell tomorrow
foreign
other scientists working in the Atlantic
had also noticed a change
oceanographer Ajit subramanian has been
working in the South Atlantic for more
than 25 years
in 2018 it was astounding how much
sargasm we ran into and it was really
striking it was something that we had
never seen before and then bam we were
there and the ship was often surrounded
by sargasm that was hundreds of meters
around the ship sargassum wasn't thought
to be found this far south we were
seeing things that we had not seen
before and I was trying to get context
for that Ajit linked up with colleagues
at the University of South Florida who'd
been making their own observations they
had been actually watching this in their
satellite data and they had actually
seen this explosion of this new
population that is growing much closer
to the Equator with the satellite data
scientists were able to Hazard an
estimate of its size
24.2 million metric tons in June from
the satellite imagery
dubbed the Great Atlantic sargassum belt
this is almost certainly the world's
largest macro algal bloom it's thought
that intensive agriculture especially
soya plantations has increased nitrogen
concentrations in the Atlantic causing
rapid sargassum growth
sargasm is really known as a symptom of
climate change because due to increasing
surface temperatures nutrients from the
Amazon and Congo Saharan dust you know
which brings in Iron upwelling as well
with changing currents all of these
factories have Lenten proliferation of
sargasm
outside of the Caribbean I don't think
many people are talking about it
hashini vamadi is a biology major
undergraduate who's recently returned
from an exploratory trip to the
Dominican Republic
it affects the Caribbean and I believe
West Africa and a bit of East Asia as
well
hashimi is part of an interdisciplinary
team from the Georgia Institute of
Technology they're working with the
school of biological sciences to try and
explore solutions to the sargassum
problem
there are lots of different plants in
here I am the biology major on our team
we have a chemical engineer a civil
engineer a mechanical engineer a
solution of some sort is definitely
needed and urgently I just didn't
realize how much of it there would be
like we watched a cleanup crew work and
work and in two hours they like hardly
made a dent
the growth just seems to be almost
exponential while there are many
creative small-scale craft uses of
sargassum local communities have yet to
find a viable solution to disposing of
vast quantities of the stuff or even
better making it useful it uptakes a lot
of different heavy metals particularly
arsenic which makes it like quite
dangerous to use as say like like a
fertilizer because again now you're
introducing arsenic to like these land
systems where it could potentially leech
into groundwater so we tried to like you
know Branch out from fertilizer one of
our team members focused on an
application involving bricks someone
else focused on black soldier fly larvae
which could consume the sargasm and then
in turn be used as like a sort of
biofuel in like anaerobic digester I
personally have been working on using it
as a biocumulate uh why not use it and
wastewater treatment it can absorb those
heavy metals that you know we were so
concerned about in the first place
hashini's team are working on ways to
make the sargassum financially viable
meanwhile Ajit is thinking more broadly
exploring the bigger checks and balances
of the global carbon cycle he's come up
with a radical plan so the way we want
to do this is essentially gather Nets of
sargassum using robotic vehicles have
them ballasted and then sink them down
2000 to 2000 meters sargassum sequested
a lot of carbon but it also releases it
when it decays this approach would
theoretically remove the carbon from the
atmosphere effectively buying the planet
time in the race against climate change
it down to 1000 meters our current model
suggests that that particular water body
does not come back in contact with the
atmosphere for at least 100 years
idea of sinking the sargasm has been
proposed before but the suggestion is
usually to sink it where it grows in
shallower water
merely capturing it at the surface and
getting rid of it
at uh just off the beach at 100 meters
or something like that we'll basically
have the carbon coming right back up it
might even actually come back up in a
more potent form if you're starting to
have it rotting and forming methane a
Jeep plans to sink the sargassum in
deeper water but there are a lot of
questions still to be answered we want
to make sure that the carbon that we are
capturing is actually going down to the
sea floor and will stay down there and
so we want to follow it down with a
submersible in addition as a biologist
he's Keen to understand the impact of
this plan on the ecosystem so we
actually have a fishery scientist from
the team who will be looking at what
kind of communities the sargassum drafts
Harbor and therefore we'll have a sense
of what we might be impacting if we
would do the thinking it's not that
we're going to decimate the ocean of
sargasm the list of problems attributed
to sargassum is growing from the harmful
gases released when it decays to its
impact on Wildlife especially when I
washes up on beaches where turtles
guggle lay their eggs a lot of these
baby turtles are actually unable to
climb over over these sarcasm things and
so they're unable to make it into the
ocean due to like these big patches of
sarcasm so every year we're seeing more
countries reporting the influx and the
catastrophic impacts on the tourism
Fisheries sectors Maritime and transport
and then the health impacts so some of
our colleagues recently published a
paper on the impacts of pregnant women
who were exposed to hydrogen sulfide and
ammonia when the sargassum you know
decomposes those pregnant ladies who
live near the cold somewhere exposed
we're at a higher risk of preeclampsia
going into the future it's likely that
the challenge presented by sargassum
like many of the challenges of climate
change might be bigger than one
scientist or one idea there needs to be
some sort of
economically driven
um or it needs to be governmental
subsidized that there needs to be some
sort of way to like tackle and solve the
problem I feel that countries like
Barbados are the populations that
contribute at least to climate change
and yet our facing the greatest impact
of climate change I would like to figure
out a financing model where we can
actually have credit going to
communities in Barbados for the carbon
that is sequestered
there are lots of bright brilliant Lanes
out there developing solutions that need
this support they need the financial
support to upskill until governments
realize that this problem is really here
to stay then they will be willing then
in investing in building I'm sargasm
Industries
nothing has like had any concrete
several isolated research groups but I
just think that things would move a lot
faster if everyone could like work
together
[Music]
foreign